اداء رائع لوصود الاطلس في كاس العالم
اسعد الجماهير وابتسموا جميعا لكن هناك
ابتسامات تلقائيه التقطتها عدسات الكاميرا
وبدات معها قصه مشجعا مغربي محمد الشرفي
تعرض لموجه تنمر عقب ظهوره على شاشات
التلفاز من مدرجات ملعب البيت في قطر وهو
يشجع منتخب بلاده امام كرواتيا وذلك بسبب
شكل السنه فئه المتنمرين هذه كتبوا
تعليقات ساخره معتبرين ان المبلغ الذي
وفره للذهاب الى قطر كان الاولى به اصلاح
شكل اسنانه قبل السفر والتفكير في السفر
على الجانب الاخر ظهرت موجته التضامن
كبيره مع الشر في ردا على هؤلاء المتنمرين
كان من بينهم طبيب الاسنان شهد الشيخ الذي
اطلق حمله
بسرعه اجمل ابتسامه للمشجع المغربي
[موسيقى]
مشكله في القلب واش انت وطني ولا ماشي
وطني الحمد لله مفاجاه الدكتور
وخليك تحجز لك سيارتي يارا انت بغيت تجي
تكمل معايا انا شفت صراحه صورته في
المباراه اللي اتوقع المغرب وكرواتيا يعني
همم للامانه قبل ما اسمع عن التنمر قبل
شيء مجرد ما شفته شيء في داخليه انا انا
كنت حاب اعمل له اسنان همم وبعد ما صارت
التنمر بتذكر قرات ما قال واحد فقط يعني
انا ما قرات ال- همم موجه من التنمر ما
اخذ مني قرار تقريبا 10 ثواني يمكن كتبت
عندي على الانستغرام اللي بيعرف همم رقم
هاتفه بس يبلغني فيه هذا كان السؤال
الوحيد خلال 15 دقيقه كان رقمه عندي
فهتواصلت معه عبر الواتساب والهاتف وقلت
له انا جاي اخذك ان شاء الله وتجيء معي
يهون على دبي تعمل اسنانك في عياد دبي
لما اتصل به اتصل بي 30 دكتور اا كل واحد
من
واشكرهم جميعا وكل واحد اختلفته لكن
كان الافضل هو شادي وما شاء الله عليه
يعني طبيب جراح جميل جدا او انا اشكرهم
هذا من القناه العربيه همم
شكرا لو شكرا لجميع من ضمن اليه واعطيني
قوه وانا الحمد لله همم في القوه الان لما
كنت في دار لما شاهدت
فوزيه المنتخب
الحمد لله اشكر الناس الذي همم يعني دافع
عني وتم يعرفوني جيدا انا مغربي يعني اصيل
همم
غير على الوطن غير على همم على البلد
الحمد لله هذا خير بالنسبه لي طيب دكتور
شادي انت تعاهد بالتحمل تكاليف سفر محمد
من قطر الى الامارات وتحمل كذلك تكاليف
صناعه اسنانه حدثنا اكثر عن الموضوع اكيد
هذا شيء يعني بسيط يعني انت مجرد ما تسمعي
حدا يتنمر على حدا ترى تنمر مش بس على
الاسنان ممكن على اشياء كثير لكن الاسنان
بدها حتى المرات الاطفال بتنمر عليهم
شعور سيء يعني انا اول ما قبلته كان حزين
وزعلان
وموضوع اكثر عليه يعني وعلى قلبه
ولما جلست معه يعني همم حسيت بقديش هو
فعلا زعل وحزن من كل اعماق قلبه انه يسمع
الناس او يقرا الناس هيك تتكلم انه والله
كل انسان عنده ظروف واذا تسمح لي بس
اخبرهم هو ما في اسنان يصلحها
عش كنا كانت تنمر بسبب بشكل اسنان هو فاقد
الاسنان هو ما في الا اربعه اسنان حتى حتى
ال ال الاجزاء العظميه يعني هو بحاجه ايضا
لزراعه عظم طيب هنا بدي اسال محمد محمد
انت قلت للناس اتنمر عليك لي قالوا ليش
يروح مباراه في قطر وهو مش قادر يدفع
صناعه اسنانه قلت عند كان عندك مشكله في
القلب مناعتك من صناعه اسنانك هل هذا فعلا
حصل
الحمد لله
هذه مشكله في العظام
عندي في العظام يعني نقص شويه في العظام
والحمد لله الدكتور هيتكلم همم
[موسيقى]